lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
explorar la continuidad sobre un
intervalo pero antes de hacer eso vamos
a recordar qué significa la continuidad
en un punto decimos que la función f es
continua
cuando x es igual a c si y sólo si el
límite cuando x tiende a c df de x es
igual a fcc la primera vez que
introdujimos esto dijimos que parecía
ser algo muy técnico pero en realidad
puede ser bastante intuitivo pensemos en
lo que está pasando aquí por ejemplo
esta parte el límite cuando x tiende
hace de la función f de x si tenemos
aquí la función que se aproxima a cierto
valor ok si nos aproximamos por la
izquierda la función se aproxima a un
valor cuando x tiende a c
y cuando la función se aproxima hace por
la derecha la función tiende al mismo
punto bueno pues para que esta función
sea continua para poder dibujar toda la
gráfica de esta función sin tener que
levantar el lápiz el valor de la función
en ese punto tiene que ser igual al
límite de esa función
en ese punto ok y esto que tenemos aquí
es simplemente una manera más formal de
describir esta noción de que para que
una función sea continua tenemos que
poder dibujarla sin levantar el lápiz
del papel ok es una manera formal de
describir esta noción de que está
conectado de que no tenemos saltos o
discontinuidades de ningún tipo pero
bueno ya que repasamos de esta parte
ahora sí vamos a hablar acerca de la
continuidad sobre todo un intervalo y no
nada más de la continuidad en un punto
para eso tenemos que borrar esto para
tener más espacio y primero vamos a
hablar de intervalos abiertos porque los
intervalos cerrados son un poquito más
complicados
decimos que f es continua en un
intervalo a c y aquí estamos diciendo
que tenemos un intervalo abierto porque
tenemos estos paréntesis si en lugar
tuviéramos unos corchetes entonces
tendríamos un intervalo cerrado pero
estos paréntesis nos dicen que no
estamos incluyendo los puntos extremos
dentro del intervalo gain ya ni se son
parte de este intervalo porque hay este
es el intervalo de todos los puntos que
se encuentran entre a y c sin incluir ni
a a ni ac ok entonces efe es continua en
el intervalo abierto a coma c si y sólo
si f es continua sobre cada punto en el
intervalo sí solo si efe es continua en
cada punto del intervalo pero bueno
ahora vamos a ver algunos ejemplos
podemos pensar en el intervalo abierto
menos 7 a menos 5 y aquí nos preguntamos
la función f es continua en el intervalo
abierto de menos 7 a menos 5
bueno pues ese es este intervalo de aquí
y aquí podríamos contestar de una forma
no muy rigurosa matemáticamente
podríamos decir oye aquí no tengo que
levantar el lápiz para dibujar este
pedazo de la gráfica pero si quisieras
demostrarlo de una forma más rigurosa y
tuvieras la definición de la función f
entonces lo que tendrías que hacer es
demostrar que para cada uno de los
puntos de este intervalo el límite
conforme x tiende a ese punto que puede
ser cualquiera de estos es igual a la
función en ese punto en particular ahora
como aquí únicamente tenemos la gráfica
de la función las cosas se complican un
poco y aquí solo lo podemos demostrar
inspeccionando la gráfica aquí lo único
que podemos decir es que podemos pasar
de este punto a este otro punto sin
levantar el lápiz del papel entonces
estamos bastante confiados de que en
este intervalo la función es continua
pero bueno ahora vamos con otro
intervalo
aquí vamos a poner una palomita de que
la función en este intervalo si es
continua pero ahora pensemos en otro
intervalo ahora vamos a ver si la
función es continua en el intervalo
abierto desde menos 2 hasta 1 positivo y
este es un ejemplo muy interesante
porque aquí tenemos un salto justo en
menos 2 entonces empezamos justo en el
menos dos tenemos que saltar para seguir
dibujando la función pero este es un
intervalo abierto entonces en realidad
no estamos empezando en el -2 realmente
no nos importa el valor de la función
exactamente en -2 lo único que nos
importa de acuerdo con este intervalo
son todos los valores que son mayores
que menos dos menores que uno pero al
menos dos no nos interesa así es que no
estamos empezando por acá podríamos
decir que estamos empezando por acá y
nos vamos hacia el 1
y de acuerdo a nuestra noción de que
aquí no estamos levantando el lápiz del
papel esa noción nos dice que la función
es continua en este intervalo pero por
supuesto también nos gustaría ver algún
ejemplo en el que la función no sea
continua y a ver pensemos en esta
gráfica donde tenemos un intervalo en el
que la función no sea continua bueno
pues por aquí tenemos otro por ejemplo
el intervalo de 3 a 5 la función está
por acá cuando x es igual a 3 y entonces
seguimos por acá y subimos y subimos y
parece como que aquí tenemos una sin
tota entonces la función se va hasta
infinito y nos quedamos mucho tiempo
dibujando la
pero luego tendríamos que tomar nuestro
lápiz despegarlo del papel para poder
dibujar el resto de la función así es
que aquí la función no es continua en
este intervalo bueno pero ahora vamos a
ver la continuidad en los intervalos que
son más complicados los intervalos
cerrados
efe es continua en el intervalo cerrado
ap si y sólo si f es continua en el
intervalo abierto a p
y el límite conforme x tiende aa por la
derecha geithner por la derecha de la
función evaluada en x es igual a efe de
a y también el límite conforme x tiende
a b por la izquierda bueno no esto va
por acá el límite cuando x tiende a b
por la izquierda de fx es igual a efe-tv
bueno pero que es lo que estamos
diciendo por aquí pues nada más estamos
diciendo que la función en los extremos
de este intervalo cerrado el límite por
dentro del intervalo conforme nos
acercamos a los extremos tiene que ser
igual al valor de la función evaluada en
el extremo entonces por ejemplo si
consideramos el intervalo cerrado menos
7 a menos 5 bueno pues aquí sigue siendo
bastante intuitivo que la función sigue
siendo continua en este intervalo
cerrado porque empezamos por aquí y no
necesitamos despegar el lápiz del papel
para
al otro extremo del intervalo cerrado
así es que la función en este intervalo
cerrado definitivamente es continua pero
incluso si la función no estuviera
definida en esta parte la función
seguiría siendo continua en el intervalo
porque el límite por la derecha conforme
nos acercamos a menos 7 aunque esta otra
parte no esté definida el límite por la
derecha sigue siendo igual al valor que
toma la función en menos 7 y lo mismo
sucede con este otro extremo el límite
por la izquierda conforme nos acercamos
a menos 5 si es igual al valor de la
función en menos 5 incluso si no
estuviera definido el límite por los dos
lados de la función en menos 5 y de
hecho tenemos un ejemplo de ese caso por
acá si nos fijamos en el intervalo que
va de menos tres a menos dos empezamos
por acá y observa no tengo que levantar
el lápiz del papel para llegar a menos
dos si tuviéramos la definición exacta
de la función f podríamos demostrar que
él
para cada uno de estos puntos dentro del
intervalo es igual a la función evaluada
en ese punto y también demostraríamos
que para estos dos extremos el límite
conforme x tiende a ellos por adentro
del intervalo es igual a la función
evaluada en ellos aunque hay porque aquí
en menos 3 la función es continua en el
sentido más básico de todos porque el
límite por los dos lados de la función
conforme de crisis tiende a menos 3 es
igual a la función evaluada en menos 3
sin embargo si analizamos el menos 2 las
cosas cambian bastante porque el límite
por los dos lados df en menos 2 ni
siquiera existe ok si tenemos el límite
por la izquierda y el límite por la
derecha pero lo importante aquí es que
el límite por la izquierda que es el
límite por adentro del intervalo es el
límite se acerca cada vez más a 0 y la
función evaluada en menos 2 es igual a 0
que el límite por la derecha cuando x
tiende a menos 2 se acerca a menos 3
entonces aunque no exista el límite por
los dos lados de f en uno de los
extremos del intervalo cerrado al menos
dos de todas formas podemos decir que la
función es continua en este intervalo
cerrado porque el límite por adentro del
intervalo de este extremo si es igual al
valor de la función en ese extremo el
límite por la izquierda de ese extremo
si es igual a la función entonces la
función si es continua sobre este
intervalo pero bueno también nos podemos
preguntar por este otro intervalo el
intervalo desde menos 2
hasta 1 y ahora te voy a pedir que le
pongas una pausa a este vídeo y pienses
si la función es continua en este
intervalo cerrado estamos hablando de
este intervalo cerrado aquí nos tenemos
que preguntar si se cumple esta
condición que el límite conforme x
tiende a por la derecha de fx es igual a
de fedea el límite conforme x tiende a a
por la derecha parece ser igual a menos
3 y la función evaluada en menos 2 es 0
entonces estos dos no son iguales el
límite conforme nos acercamos por la
derecha no es igual a la función
evaluada en el extremo entonces no se
está cumpliendo esta propiedad aunque
podríamos decir que no tenemos esta
continuidad lateral porque el límite por
la derecha de esta función en menos 2 no
es igual al valor de la función y eso
tiene mucho sentido porque si empezamos
a dibujar en
y quiero dibujar el resto de la función
en este intervalo pues tengo que
levantar el lápiz tengo que levantar el
lápiz para moverme hasta acá para poder
dibujar el resto de la función en este
intervalo entonces como aquí tuvimos que
saltar esta función no es continua en
este intervalo cerrado
y listo terminamos